Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two David P.. Here's
a call I got about Prager U. Video is
being shown in school. Listen to this.
Speaker 4: Hi, David, I'm a middle school social
studies teacher and I want to share with you
something that happened at my school this week. So
one of my colleagues, also social studies teacher,
got called into a meeting with the principal and
afterwards he had told us the story. Apparently, a
parent voiced a concern about something in his
lesson and it turned out that he had shown the
class of video from Craker you. And one of the
students noticed this source as something to
be wary of and kind of raised that concern
with the parent who contacted the school.
I just wanted to kind of share that with
you and say, you know, I thought it was
kind of I was proud that there were students out
there that were being considerate and critical
of the sources that they're encountering.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. Whatever kid did that
has upper management written all over him or her?
No, I mean, listen, Prager, you in social studies,
that is not good. That is really, really not
good. And I if I had a kid in school right now,
I would be first of all, I would be losing
my mind if they came home and said, sir,
that my kids would call me sir. If they said, sir,
we were shown programing videos, but I would be
wanting to go out of my way to prepare them and
say, listen. You might be shown videos in school,
you know, little Rifka or little little Mortdecai,
you might be shown videos in school. Just because
your teacher chooses the video doesn't mean you
can believe everything in the video. You always
have to think for yourself and if you ever have
a question, you come to me, son or daughter. You
know what? Anyway, the point is, I'm joking about
how I would say it, but I would go out of my way
to prepare my kids for the fact that you may
be shown things that are not representative,
representing the world as it is. And certainly
Prager, you videos and social studies class would
be very, very high on that list, but good on that
kid for doing it. We have a great bonus show for
you today. Poverty fell in 2020. Why stimulus
checks and enhanced unemployment? Very simple.
We will talk about Wal-Mart and Ford teaming
up on self-driving deliveries. And Beddoe
O'Rourke is looking like he's going to run for
governor against Texas Governor Greg Abbott.
I love this. And it will give us another
great race, a great race for the coming
election cycle. All of those stories and more
on today's bonus show. Sign up at David Pakman.
Speaker 2: Dotcom, get yourself instant access.
Unidentified: I will see you the.